وصف حلف شمال الاطلسي النيت قراره بتقليص
عملياته المشتركه مع الجيش الافغاني بانه
احترازي ومؤقت ياتي قرار الحلف بالحد من
تعاونه مع القوات الافغانيه بعد سلسله
هجمات نفذها جنود افغان ضد قوات
[موسيقى]
النيت
حياكم الله نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
عنوانين رئيسيين ما مغزى اضطرار النيتو
الى اتخاذ هذا القرار في هذه الظروف وما
مدى وجاهه الدوافع التي ساقها لتبريره
وعلى اي وجه يمكن ان تنعكس مثل هذه
القرارات على مستقبل افغانستان ومصير مهمه
القوات الدوليه فيها
[موسيقى]
تحت وطاه تزايد اعداد الضحايا في صفوف
القوات الدوليه بافغانستان الذين يسقطون
برصاص زملائهم والمتدربين تحت ايديهم من
المجندين الافغان اتخذ قائد القوات
الدوليه في افغانستان الجنرال جون الن
قرارا بتقليص التعاون العملياتي بين قواته
ونظيرتها الافغانيه نص الامر العسكري
الصادر في هذا الشان على ايقاف عمل
الوحدات المشتركه التي يقل تعدادها عن 800
عسكري الا بقرار من قاده المناطق وبعد
دراسه كل حاله على حده وهو ما يعني تعويق
وتيره هذه العمليات اذا قدر لها ان تتم
اصلا محاوله جديده وليست شكليه من قياده
القوات الاجنبيه في افغانستان لوقف عداد
القتلى في صفوف جنودها ممن يسقطون برصاص
زملائهم الافغان 51 هذه السنه وحده ذلك ما
جعل دولا كفرنسا تعلن سحب قواتها المقاتله
مبكرا قبل
2014 بعد تعليق تدريب المجندين تقضي اوامر
عسكريه باخضاع التعاون مع القوات
الافغانيه على مستوى اقل من الكتيبه
لتقدير الموقف حاله بحاله وموافقه من قائد
منطقه عسكريه وتعلق المهام المشتركه في
خطوط المواجهه في الوحدات التي يقل عديدها
عن 800
عسكري رغم استمرار اغلب الدوريات والعمل
الاستشاري على مستوى الكتائب فما فوق وعدم
تاثر مهام المسانده الجويه للقوات
الافغانيه فان الجانب البريطاني بدا وكانه
فوجئ بالقرار الذي صدر بعد يوم واحد من
مرافعه وزير الدفاع عن فوائد التعاون مع
الجيش
الافغاني لدينا مخطط استراتيجي ونعمل على
انهاء عملنا القتالي بحلول
2014 الموقف نفسه اكده وزير الدفاع
الامريكي ليون بانيتا من الصين مع حرصه
على توضيح يراه
مهما انهم يجتهدون لضرب قواتنا لخلق
الفوضى لكن لا ينجم عن ذلك باي حال من
الاحوال استعاده طالبان مناطق فقط السيطره
عليها حلف شمال الاطلس يقول ان الخطوه
مؤقته لكن هل ستؤثر على مفاوضات بين
واشنطن وكابل على ابقاء قوات خاصه ومدربين
بعد
2014 كال المتوقع لا يقابل الحرص على مصير
الجنود الاجانب ايه اجراءات فعاله لتجنيب
المدنيين الافغان ويلات غارات الطيران
الحربي الاجنبي وهي من اسباب النقمه
والانتقام من الوجود الدولي في
افغانستان لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من
كابل الكاتب والمحلل السياسي حبيب حكيمي
من واشنطن معنا جيسن كامبل الباحث في
مؤسسه راند سيد كامبل لننظر الى احد جوانب
هذا القرار وهو يبدو وكانه بمثابه اعلان
فقدان ثقه بين قوات التحالف والجيش
الافغاني ما هو مغزى القرار في بعده
هذا انا ساكون حذرا
استخدام عبارات شديده مثل فقدان الثقه
بالكامل مثلا لكن اقول ان الطالبان حققوا
غرضهم من وراء هذه الهجمات باشا جو من عدم
الثقه بين الطرفين بشكل عام نعم وهذا ما
اردته طالبان وهذا ما حققته لكن الزمن فقط
هو الذي سينبانا عن اثار ذلك
المستقبليه يعني لننظر الى
التبريرات التي قدمت احد هذه المبررات كان
الحديث عن الفيلم المسيء للاسلام مع العلم
ان
الشهر السابق كان هناك اكثر من 12 هجوم
وسقط في 36 ام
ضحيه هل ترى ان هذا التبرير منطقي
مقنع او عفوا 15 ضحيه
بالحر لا لا ارى الامر كذلك لانه من
الصعوبه بمكان ان نعثر على ايه تبريرات
لكن هناك الكثير من القضايا التي تزعزع
الاستعر الاستقرار زياده هذه الحالات
حالات هجمات قوات صديقه ضد قواتها الحليفه
والاعتبار ان السبب هو هذا الفيلم المسيء
للاسلام او وجود
هجمات واضحه قويه في وضح النهار ضد اماكن
عسكريه محصنه كما حصل في هلمن اعتقد ان
نتيجه كل ذلك دفع بالقاده الميدانيين الى
اخذ خطوه الى الوراء ليبحثوا في اسباب هذه
الوضعيه للابقاء على سلامه امن افراد
قواتهم بالطبع في الواقع كانت هناك مقدمه
سيد حكيم لهذا القرار فقبل اسبوعين فقط
علقت قياده العمليات
الخاصه دوريات المشتركه مع الجيش الافغاني
فهل من وجهه نظركم كانت هذه خطوه متوقعه
كيف نظرتم اليها في
افغانستان الخطوه كانت متوقعه لان الهجمات
ضد القوات الاجنبيه على يد جنود افغان
ازدادت في الاوه الاخيره حيث ا اكثر من 50
جنديا اجنبيا قتلوا على يد زملائهم في
القواعد العسكريه المحسنه امنيا للقوات
الاجنبيه في مناطق مختلفه في هذا البلد
وهذه الخطوه في الوقت نفسي
باعتقادي تعتبر تراجعا كبيرا وخطوه كبيرا
الى الوراء في استراتيجيه قوات النيتو في
افغانستان لان قوات
النيتو والقوات الافغانيه
تحتاج الى القوات الاجنبيه في تدريبيه في
رفع مستوى كفاءاتها وفي اعدائها في
المعارك ضد الجماعات المسلحه
وحركه طالبان والقوات الافغانيه والحكومه
الافغانيه بحاجه ماسه الى هذه التدريبات
والى دعم من قبل القوات الاجنبيه لقواتها
حتى تصبح قادره على تسلم المهام الامنيه
في افغانستان بعد عام
2014 وهناك مناطق تخضع لسيطره طالبان
والقوات الافغانيه حتى هذه اللحظه ليست
قادره بوحدها لشن هجمات واجراء العمليات
العسكريه ضد الجماعات المسلحه وعلى راسها
طالبان لتصفيه هذه المناطق وبالتالي غير
قادره على التصدي للهجمات التي تقوم بها
حركه طالبان بين حين واخر في المناطق
المحسنه
امنيا الهجمات الانتحاريه والهجمات
التفجيريه وحتى حركه طالبان تستطيع ان ان
اي ان تصل الى الاهداف المهمه والى
المناطق الحساسه داخل العاصمه كابل
وتستطيع ان ت تخترق صفوف الجيش الافغاني
والشرطه الافغانيه هذه هي المشاكل التي
تواجهها القوات الامنيه الافغانيه
وبالتالي المشكله الاخرى التي تواجهها
القوات الاجنبيه هي مشكله من قبل زملائهم
هم لا يتعرضون للاخطار في المعارض مع
طالبان والجماعات المسلحه في ميادين
القالق واعد العسكريه المحس وهذه المشكله
هي التي اصبحت مصدر قلق للولايات المتحده
وقوات النيتو في في افغانستان ومنذ
البدايه القوات الاجنبيه والولايات
المتحده تحديدا كانت تدرس هذه المشكله حتى
تجد لها حلا ولكن لاسباب كثيره ولمشاكل
كثيره ولعل كثيره حتى الان القوات
الاجنبيه لم تستطيع ان تضع حدا لهذه
الهجمات انت برايك يعني ما هو السبب
الاساسي تقول اسباب
كثيره
السبب الاساسي في هذه الهجمات هناك اسباب
كثيره باعتقادي السبب الاساسي هو
اختراق طالبان لصفوف الجيش الافغاني لان
حركه طالبان منبثقه من هذا الوسط
الاجتماعي ومن هذا المعيط المحيط ومن هذه
القبائل خاصه في المناطق الشرقيه
والجنوبيه
التي تسكن
فيها غالبيه القبائل البشتون حركه هذه
المناطق تحتضن حركه طالبان وبالاساس حركه
طالبان منبثقه من هذه
الاوساط القبليه ولذلك تستطيع حركه طالبان
ان تستخدم الانتحاريين وتخترق صفوف الجيش
الافغاني بالنهايه الجيش الافغاني والشرطه
الافغانيه كذلك مكونان من هذه من هؤلاء
الاشخاص وهم ياتون الى وينضمون الى الجيش
الافغاني وياتون الى المدن الكبرى من هذه
المناطق وليست هناك اجراءات امنيه
واجراءات
استخباريه تستطيع ان تحط من من هذه
المشكله ولذلك حركه طالبان تستطيع ان
تخترق صفوف الجيش الافغاني وتنفذ داخل
الجيش الافغاني وهناك عناصر فعلا داخل
الاجهزه الامنيه الافغانيه تصاقط عركه
طالبان في مثل في مثل هذه بغض النظر عن
الاسباب
سي اذا اردت ان تضيف فكره بس بسرعه لو
سمحت لان الوقت قصير
جدا سيد حكيم معره نقطه تريد ان تضيفها
بشكل
سريع نعم اسمعك تفضلي طيب ل نكتفي بهذا
القدر تحدثت عن اسباب مختلفه بغض النظر عن
عن هذه
الاسباب صحيفه الجارديان وهنا انتقل لضيف
في واشنطن صحيفه الجارديان تتحدث عن ان
القرار وتعتبر القرار صفعه لخطط واشنطن في
افغانستان من حيث انه دليل على ان القوات
الدوليه المناط بها حمايه افغانستان اصبحت
عاجزه عن توفير هذا الامان الحد الادنى من
الامان لافرادها ما
تعليقك جيسن كامبل
تفضل اعتقد ان علينا ان نتانى ونحضر قبل
الخروج باستنتاجات استراتيجيه طويله المدى
لكن علينا على الاقل ان نبحث نقطتين اولا
ان نقف لبره تلقي نظره متانيه وفاحص فيما
يخص العمليات المشتركه على نطاق واسع
حقيقه كانت في حاله من التراجع في عموم
البلاد اضافه الى ان قدره المجتمع الدولي
على توفير الرعايه والتمرينات والتدريبات
للقوات الافغانيه هنا تكمن مشكله كبيره
ولا شك لان هذا الوقف او التعليق قد يكون
مؤقتا بضعه ايام فقط وقد حدث من قبل في
العام الماضي عندما تعرضت قوات النيتو
لهجمات معينه سحبت قياده قوات النيتو
افرادها من المدربين من قواعد معينه وماكن
تدريب معينه لكنها لم تدم اكثر من بضعه
ايام لذلك من السابق لاوانها ان نقول ان
هذا الامر سيستمر الى الابد وعلينا نتظر
قليلا قبل ان نخرج استنتاجات استراتيجيه
واسعه النطاق
ولكن يبقى السؤال كيف سينعكس هذا القرار
واي قرار مماثل على خطه مستقبل افغانستان
وخطط النيتو بشانها هذا ما سنناقشه بعد
فاصل قصير ارجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد الى حلقتنا التي
تتناول الاسباب التي دفعت النيتو لتقليص
عملياتها المشتركه مع القوات الافغانيه
واثر ذلك على مستقبل
افغانستان
اذا عاد كانت لدينا مشكله صغيره في
الاتصال مع افغانستان عاد ضيفنا من
افغانستان اريد ان اسالك السيد جيسن كامبل
اولا وزير الخارجيه البريطاني في حكومه
الظل دجلس الكساندر تساءل عن عدم تطرق
وزير الدفاع البريطاني لهذا القرار في
حديثه امام برلمان امس بل توعد الحكومه
باخضاع لاسئله محرجه في هذا
الصدد هل يشير هذا هل هذا هناك مؤشر الى
حدوث خلل في
التحالف وغياب تنسيق اذا صح
التعبير لا استطيع ان اسمي ذلك مشكله في
التواصل والتنسيق لكن التقارير الاوليه
تفيد بان قرار الايساف جاء
مفاجئا وليس فقط البريطانيين حتى القوات
الاستراليه بدات وكانها فوجئت بالقرار لكن
من المهم ان نشير الى ان بعض الامور
الاخرى التي تزعزع من استقرار افغانستان
وربما لم يتم الحديث عنها من قبل كان هناك
معلومات استخبار
عن اما عن طريق جهاز الاستخبارات الافغاني
او جهاز
استخبارات سف تحذر من امكانيه تعليق
مفاجئه للعمليات المشتركه لذلك لا نعرف
الكثير عن الاسباب وعلينا ننتظر ماال
الامور طيب الحديث عن توقف عمليات
التدريب هذا بحد ذاته اليس هناك خوف ان
يعيد افغانستان حاضنه الارهاب من جديد سيد
حكيمي استفيد من هذا الفراغ في هذه
المرحله والمرحله المقبله و بس
ستكون انشط من من قبل في المناطق التي
تنشط فيها وفي المناطق التي تشنها جمتها
وبالتالي ه هذه الخطوه تقوي الروح
المعنويه لدى مقاتلي طالبان والذ الذين
يساعدون طالبان في
المناطق المختلفه وبالتالي هناك الجهات
التي تدعم حركه طالبان من خارج افغانستان
هذه الجهات
ستكثف دعمها لحركه طالبان باعتقادي و
وبالتالي حركه طالبان الامل سيكون اقوى من
قبل لدى حركه طالبان هي ستستطيع ان تعود
الى الى الساحه الافغانيه بقوه والى الى
السلطه بعد رحيل القوات الاجنبيه من
افغانستان
خاصه
خاصه على الاقل تستطيع ان ان ان ان تسيطر
على اجزاء كبيره من افغانستان انا
باعتقادي حتى بعد رحيل القوات الاجنبيه من
الصعب لحركه طالبان ان تسيطر على
افغانستان تماما وتحكم افغانستان لانها
ستواجه مقاومه في مناطق اخر افغانستان
واجهت مقاومه شرسه من قبل سان المناطق
الشمال والمناطق المرز التسعينيات من
القرن الماض وهذا السارو باعتقاد سيتكرر
ولكن من المؤكد ان هذا التراجع على الاقل
يساعد دخول
افغانستان حرب اهليه ودخول
افغانستان
حمامم من جد اذا انهار الجش الافغاني واذا
انهارت المؤسسات الامنيه في افغانستان بعد
رحيل القوات الاجنبيه بالتاكيد افغانستان
ستدخل في حرب
اهليه اخرى هذا الكلام يتوافق مع ما قاله
الجنرال مارتن دمسي قائد القوات الامريكيه
المشتركه قال ان الهجمات تمثل تهديد جدي
للحمله العسكريه في افغانستان من المفارقه
وهنا اوجه السؤال لجي جيسون كامبل
المفارقه ان ليون بانتا وزير الفاع
الامريكي بالامس فقط قال كلام مختلف
تماما يعني يعتبر الهجمات دليل على ضعف
طالبان ف يعني كيف تفسر هذا
التناقض مره اخرى وللاسف اعتقد انه من
السابق لاوانه الخروج باستنتاج لكن ما هو
واضح ان طالبان تغير من اساليبها في
محاوله لزياده مساله فقدان الثقه بين
القوات الافغانيه والقوات الدوليه وتحاول
التاثير في عقليات وذهني رجل الشارع
العادي في افغانستان لتفهم الناس بانها ما
زالت قوه لها اعتبارها ولا يستهان بها وهي
لاعب اساسي ونحن نقبل على مرحله من
القوات الاجنبيه وهذا يظهر انهم يبذلون
جهودا اضافيه الان لكن هل سيستطيعون
الابقاء على هذه الحاله من النشاط
المتزايد حتى نهايه العام 2013 لا ندري
علينا ان ننتظر لنرى طيب واضح جيس كب لا
يريد ان يستنتج من هذا التناقض او يقرا
فيه ماذا تقرا في انت سيد
حكيمي
انا باعتقادي حركه طالبان لم تضعف ب
انما اصبحت اقوى من قبل وفي هذه المرح اذا
قارنا لا اسالك عن التناقض في التصريحات
الامريكيه ماذا تقرا في هذا
التناقض التناقض باعتقادي تاتي من من
السياسه غير الواضحه تجاه حركه طالبان
والجماعات المسلحه في افغانستان نحن في
الفتره الماضيه شاهدنا سياسات مختلفه هناك
سياسه للولايات المتحده وهناك سياسه مختصه
لبريطانيا والدول الغربيه الكبرى وال هذه
الدول
الكل ينظر الى الى القضيه
بمنظار مختلف وليست هناك على الاقل
استراتيجيه عسكريه واضحه لمواجهه طالبان
على سبيل المثال مره الولايات المتحده
تتحدث عن المصالحه مع حركه طالبان
والجماعات المسلحه المسانده لحركه طالبان
في هذه المنطقه على سبيل المثال شبكه
حقاني ومره اخرى مباشره تعلن الولايات
المتحده ان هذه المفاوضات مع شبكه حقاني
وحركه طالبان في في مستويات مختلفه انهارت
و
وتعلن ادخال شبكه حقاني في لائحه الجماعات
الارهابيه وكذلك تتحدث عن المصالحه معرك
مع حركه طالبان حركه طالبان ترفض هذه
السياسات هي التي
جعلت باعتقاد المسؤولين الكبار في
الولايات المتحده سواء المسؤولين
العسكريين او او
المدنيين يدلون بتصريحات متناقضه بين حين
واخر نظرا للاوضاع على الارض ونظرا
للمستجدات على الارض في
افس هو كيف سيؤثر القرار على انسحاب
القوات القوات الامريكيه من افغانستان
برايك هل سيكون له
تاثير
سيد
حكيمي السؤال مؤجل نعم بشكل سريع لو تكرمت
لنا في الدقائق
الاخيره نعم هذا القرار سيؤثر كثيرا وهذا
باعتقادي
يخلق شيئا من القلق داخل القوات الاجنبيه
بانها بان وجودها لم ينفع ولم ينجح في اي
في
دعم الجيش الافغاني والقوات الامنيه
الافغانيه وفي دعم الحكومه الافغانيه وهذه
القوات لن تكون قادره في الم المستقبل
لتسلم المهام الامنيه في افغانستان رغم
هذه الجهود الجباره وهذه المبالغ الهائله
التي صرفت لتدريبها وتعليمها وتجهيزها
وهذا طبعا لدى الحكومات الغرب الغربيه
كذلك يخلق نوعا نوعا من من الياس وكذلك
لدى الشعوب الغربيه وبالتالي يؤثر على على
الانسحاب الامريكي في عام 2014 انا اعتقد
الانسحاب سيكون وفق خطه موضوعه ولكن على
الاقل معنويا يؤثر على على على الجنود
الاجانب في
افغانستان وايضا بطريقه و باخرى السييد
جيسون كامبل يؤثر على وضع اوباما نفسه في
هذه الايام الحرجه هو من وضع الاستراتيجيه
زياده القوات عام 2010 و واضح بغض ورغم
اصرارك على عدم تسميتها بفشل صراع
بالاستنتاج ولكنها بلا شك تضع علامه
استفهام كبيره حول هذه
الاستراتيجيه كيف سيكون تاثيرها على موقفه
في الانتخابات اذا كان برايك سيكون ساكون
مختصرا ايضا فيما يخص
الانتخابات في الحقيقه
الانتخابات معركتها محتدمه في الولايات
المتحده لكن بصراحه قضيه افغانستان لم
تدخل دائره الدجل الجدل عفوا والسبب في
ذلك لان كلا الطرفين قد لا يتفقان في
الرؤيه ولكن خططهما لا تختلف كثيرا عن ما
يريدون تحقيقه لذا علينا ان ننتظر حتى
العام 2014 فالقضيب ليست ق ترى ان
الانسحاب سيتم في وقته
ستتركونه بايدي قوات غير
مدربه
اعتقد ان الانسحاب سيحدث في وقته لكنني
اعتقد اننا في اعقاب الانتخابات الامريكيه
ربما سنبدا بالتفاوض مع حكومه كارزي لنرى
ما يمكن ابقائه من قوات بعد الانسحاب
واعتقد ان هناك حاجه ستستمر للتدريب تستمر
ما وراء عام 2014 وهذا ما تدركه كل
الاطراف ربما تجدر الاشاره بحسب تقرير من
معهد انتم في في راند الحديث عن ان
التدريب يعني هو ثلاثه اسابيع فقط للجنود
الافغان بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر نشكر ضيفين السيد حبيب
حكيمي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من كابل ومن
واشنطن جيسن كامبل الباحث في مؤسسه راند
ونشكركم مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه هذه
الحلقه نلتقي باذن الله في حلقه جديده من
ما وراء الخبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في